il ya un an la municipalité instaurer
une taxe sur les commerces vacants
avec succès puisque une vingtaine
d'entre eux ont trouvé repreneur
sur ce modèle une taxe sur les logements
vacants va voir le jour avec des
critères précis comme la durée de
vacances pour y échapper ou s'il soumet
l'objectif c'est de remettre sur le
marché tout un tas de logements qui
aujourd'hui sont inoccupés en centre
ville comme dans le reste des quartiers
de la ville d'ailleurs c'est une mesure
qui va vraiment concernés l'intégralité
de la ville de châteauroux on a perdu
dix mille habitants en 40 ans qui sont
éparpillés parce que les gens trouvaient
pas sur châteauroux le produit qui leur
convenait aujourd'hui je pense que le
moment est venu de faire machine arrière
et de remettre sur le marché
ces logements pour ramener de la
population certains logements mis en
vente ou en location ne trouve pas
preneur
nous avons demandé un professionnel
quels étaient les critères pour réussir
une transaction notamment dans le
secteur locatif du centre ville nous a
emmenés voir un appartement de l'hyper
centre pour que l'on comprenne mieux la
résidence date des années 80 nous
engageons nos propriétaires à faire des
travaux relativement lourd significatif
en tout cas on fait les soldes les
peintures mais des équipements manière à
ce qu'il soit attractif de nouveau et ça
marche ça marche parce que dès qu'on a
rénové 1 il est loué dans les jours qui
suivent donc il est important de rénover
de remettre les appartements au goût du
jour
si on veut que le marché immobilier
locatif soit actif dans secteur privé
selon la municipalité
la taxe pourrait générer 400 mille euros
de recettes qui seraient réinjectés pour
la rénovation des façades et la
réfection des trottoirs mais la finalité
reste bien sûr que les propriétaires
prennent des décisions pour remettre
leurs biens sur le marché